to have an accurate GPS you also know
you are very accurate clocks if you set
for clocks and give them enough time
they'll all start to disagree clocks
have a tendency to drift so how do you
define a second down to its most minut
measurability where I'm going in Boulder
Colorado tries to answer exactly that
question they quite literally set the
standard of what a second is because
among their labs along with
nanotechnology and quantum computers
they have the one clock that sets them
all the second didn't have a real
standard of measurement until the late
60s and the place that set that standard
of measurement is where I'm headed today
it's the National Institute of Standards
and Technology I'm going to NIST my name
is Steve Jeffords and I'm the guy who
was responsible for the group designing
and building primary frequency standards
in earnest the National Institute of
Standards and Technology or NIST is
constantly working to build better
clocks this new atomic time standard the
f2 fountain clock is the most accurate
clock of its kind in the world
if NIST f2 ran continuously for 300
million years it would not stray from
perfect time by one second there's
really much more an experiment than a
clock this is not that first of all
there are no hands hmm and that's that's
I mean the no hands is a joke but on the
other hand it's it's really also
fundamental what we do is tell you how
fast the clock is running
not what time it is we measure the
length of a second but we don't tell you
which second is which the new clock is
three times more accurate than the
previous NIST standard this step one
International System of Units the second
is defined as the energy splitting
between two states in a cesium atom and
for cesium that splitting is by
definition in the S
I system 9,192,631,770 Hertz or cycles
per second so if I measure the radiation
associated with that transition in
cesium atoms and I count 9,192,631,770
cycles one second is one by the most
important precision timing usage comes
out of global navigation systems GNSS
which I yes why does GPS need time I'm
standing here in the laboratory with my
GPS receiver and there's a satellite
over there satellite over there and all
of them are beaming radio signals to me
that tell me
hi I'm satellite 18 and my position in
space is this and my time is this and I
get the signal from him and I get the
signal from him the signal from him
comes to me at the speed of light so his
time arrives to me late by the distance
and his time arrives to me late by that
distance you can have this to each
satellite right and the only way it
makes sense is if the I have to assume
that the clocks are synchronized yeah if
they're random it doesn't work they have
to all be the same right several
improvements were made in NIST F 2 the
most important being to nearly eliminate
small errors caused by background
radiation this scientists use that
second to recalibrate their commercial
atomic clocks which run more reliably
but aren't nearly as accurate as a
cesium fountain
we need ultra accurate time for a host
of applications including the global
positioning system telecommunications
and the internet we use the relative
frequency measurements of these clocks
to test whether or not these assumptions
of fundamental physics are true yeah and
if the laws of physics are changing the
clock rates should move with respect to
each other the other thing you could
imagine happening is if say general
relativity was not quite right you could
imagine that the clock rates of the
different clocks depended upon we're in
the orbit around the Sun we work I mean
what you're talking about is testing
some of these like absolutely most
fundamental basic assumptions about how
the universe works right and the reason
we want to do that with clocks is that
fundamentally these are the most
accurate measurement devices we've ever
built so we can make more accurate
measurements this way and really precise
measurement